[Musica]
[Applauso]
in cartongesso
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh
[Musica]
mi posso sedere insieme a voi
posso però io mi siedo qua questa è la
mia sedia
vi vedo anche meglio
sono davide locatelli 26 anni
professione musicista pianista sono
diplomato al conservatorio lucio
campiani di mantova il pianoforte e
questa è un po la mia vita vita che
iniziata nel 1992 quando sono nato il 22
agosto e all'età di quattro anni ho
iniziato a suonare le prime note grazie
a mio padre
anche gli pianista anche gli diplomato
al conservatorio di mantova dal mio
stesso maestro quindi siamo una bella
triade collegata da tanti tanti anni
inizialmente il mio percorso da pianista
non era esattamente quello che avete
visto adesso con il tema dei pirati dei
carabi che ho riprodotto alla mia
maniera
e che è uno dei miei ultimi singoli sono
partito come musicista classico e 19
anni sono stato uno dei cinque italiani
che si è diplomato al conservatorio
sotto i 20 anni
da qui inizia un bellissimo viaggio
fatto di un sacco di strada è tortuosa e
difficile che adesso vado a raccontarvi
inizialmente il giorno del diploma mi
ricordo che tornai a casa ed ero
veramente stanco di tutta la mole di
studio che c'era stata fino a quel
momento e dissi a mio padre che io di
quella musica non volevo più avere a che
fare non mi interessava più e da qui
sono iniziati i primi problemi con la
famiglia che voleva per me un percorso
classico ma io ero un cosiddetto ribelle
che amava fare altro
da qui iniziano i primi litigi fino a
che per un paio d'anni non ho più
rivolto non ci siamo più rivolti parola
io e mio padre sono stato per un paio
d'anni new york per chiarirmi le idee ho
suonato in tanti posti lì mi sono preso
un bagaglio culturale veramente
importante ho fatto la cosiddetta
gavetta suonando in pub da poche persone
fino arrivare al blue note a new york
che è stato per me una pietra miliare
che mi porto veramente addosso sempre
nel 2015 torno in italia e partecipo
importante trasmissione televisiva con
un'interpretazione di musicista classico
tal signor a vivaldi e porto l'estate di
vivaldi appunto in chiave rock questa
cosa in qualche modo mi ha fatto
riavvicinare a mio papà perché aveva
visto che in fondo si era sbagliato
quando qualche anno prima mi aveva un po
denigrato e quella è stata la mia
rivincita ed è stato un po il punto di
inizio della mia carriera perchè dopo
quel momento sono iniziati i concerti i
primi contatti importanti e tra le varie
ospitate televisive nel 2017 o
totalizzato più di cento concerti in
giro per l'italia e l'europa e in quel
momento questo strumento era diventato
il mio vero lavoro eccessivamente
vedevo che mi mancava qualcosa non mi
sentivo ancora completo e dentro di me
avevo necessità di sapere di più fino a
quando un paio di anni fa decisi che la
sola musica classica che mi aveva
formato della musica pop che mi aveva
proseguito nel mio cammino non era
sufficiente allora dall'inizio non gli
studi di musica jazz dove dalla semplice
passatemi il termine reinterpretazione
di pezzi si passa all improvvisazione
improvvisazione che è la capacità di
poter chiedere una nota ad uno qualsiasi
nel pubblico e di poter iniziare un
qualunque brano immagino che voi
sappiate quali siano le sette note
sbaglio c'è qualcuno che vuole dirmi una
nota a caso la ok
noi da questo la ora partiremo e chissà
dove andremo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
beh questo è una cosa molto molto
semplice che si può fare partendo da una
singola nota
ma torniamo a noi
[Musica]
il mio percorso si è sviluppato quando
un giorno decisi che questo strumento
per lo più visto per persone di nicchia
per persone più abbienti
doveva essere usufruibile anche dal
popolo dalle persone comuni che di
pianoforte non ne sanno niente e da qui
nasce anche la mia idea di pormi al
popolo dare al popolo quello che il
popolo vuole infatti due mi vedete così
ma in verità io sono cosa
perché ormai la cultura del 2019 questa
noi siamo così noi giovani siamo così e
quindi mi sono fatto un po il portatore
della musica strumentale in giro per
l'italia
mi sono fatto il portavoce di tutti
coloro che hanno un sogno e lo vogliono
realizzare tramite uno strumento e
tramite una passione
io nel mio piccolo penso che in tutti
questi anni di grande gavetta e grande
impegno perché per fare questo di
mestiere è veramente veramente dura
veramente dura perché ci vuole tanto
impegno tanta costanza e tanta passione
soprattutto bisogna essere fiduciosi in
se stessi diciamo che tutto tutti questi
aggettivi mi hanno portato nel tempo a
lavorare con le persone con cui lavoro
attualmente ma la musica al giorno
d'oggi è vista secondo il mio punto di
vista come un mix tra generi tra mondi
le note come abbiamo appena detto
sono sette quindi abbiamo abbastanza
sentito tutto e quindi per andare alla
ricerca di qualcosa di nuovo
bisogna fondere i generi bisogna fondere
le canzoni io voglio fare un esempio e
magari vi faccio sentire un pezzetto di
quella che era una band che tempi era
super avanti e il signor freddie mercury
era veramente un genio veramente un
genio
quest'anno pochi mesi fa uscito il film
sui queen bohemian rhapsody che descrive
abbastanza bene quello che è stata la
vita di questo genio come la creatività
l'ha portato essere collocherà io voglio
suonarvi un pezzetto di bohemian
rhapsody perché la considero una vera
opera club
rock musica classica rock negli anni 80
nessuno sapeva cos'era però quest'uomo
con il suo genio era già avanti tutti
sapeva già che doveva mixare le due cose
e ne uscita buemi herat city
[Musica]
grazie
bene siamo arrivati alla fine
volevo solo lasciarvi con una mia
piccola testimonianza che è poi la
verità è che e di cui ne vado molto
fiero
io quando cambiato totalmente il mio
modo di approcciarmi uno strumento
perché non lo sentivo mio avevo contro
tutti e tutto dalla famiglia agli amici
tutti mi dicevano che ero impazzito e io
sono stato felice di esserlo perché ora
a distanza di anni
lui è diventata la mia vita lui è
diventato il mio lavoro e se credete
veramente in qualcosa portata la fino in
fondo perché i primi ad essere pazzi e
quelli che verranno sempre portato in
palmo di mano di tutti sono quelli che
hanno avuto il coraggio di voler andare
oltre alla normalità delle semplici cosa
grazie
[Applauso]